la tête devient chaud la bataille contre
la réforme des retraites a commencé dans
la rue
avec une mobilisation record dans toute
la France
alors que le débat s'ouvre à l'Assemblée
nationale les députés s'activent sur le
terrain pour faire valoir leurs
arguments
d'un côté les parlementaires expliquent
que la réforme est incontournable
je suis opposé j'aimerais aussi entendre
des propositions alternatives et
vraiment qu'elle soit portée et on peut
pas être dans un déni de réalité
lorsqu'on affronte des sujets complexes
il faut les prendre à bras le corps
c'est ça le courage de l'autre les oppos
qui s'active pour gagner la bataille de
l'opinion qui était à la manifestation
jeudi dernier
sur le principe on est contre parce que
on part du principe que c'est injuste en
justifié
député en action pour ou contre la mer
des réformes du 2e quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron
[Musique]
député du Rhône Jean-Luc fujit est un
des rares parlementaires renaissances
qui va au contact des électeurs pour
défendre la réforme
donc organise chaque député organise
donc la rencontre ainsi concitoyens
comme il le conçoit à travers
mais si vous voulez moi je pense que
c'est important et puis c'est important
aussi de pouvoir
percevoir les désaccords qu'il y a et
les désaccords font partie du débat
démocratique et donc avant le débat donc
au Parlement la semaine prochaine en
séance publique je pense qu'il est
intéressant que je ressente la réalité
de ce que pensent les et ceux qui que je
vais rendre coger ou que je vais
rencontrer dans ces dans ces soirées
débats
ce soir là à Condrieu dans la banlieue
de Lyon
il va jouer les VRP d'une réforme
qui a du mal à passer
bon bonsoir à toutes et tous et puis bah
merci d'être venu à cette assemblée
citoyenne je vais passer donc la parole
tout de suite à Jean-Michel il se
présente il se présente les données
premier acte convaincre que cette
réforme est indispensable
important la pérennité de notre régime
de retraite n'est pas assuré on a en 70
trois cotises pour un seul retraité en
2023 aujourd'hui 1,7 cotisants pour un
retraité en 2050 ce sera 1,4 cotisante
pour un retraité et donc la suite semble
couler
de sophro reculer à 64 ans l'âge de
départ à la retraite et exiger 43 ans de
cotisations pour toucher sa pension sans
décote je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci Jean-Michel
alors il veut
ça peut être des avis des questions de
demande de précision si on les en
voulait donnera la masse considérable
d'exonération de charme des entreprises
à l'heure actuelle ne seraient-elles pas
impossible répartition autre de l'effort
le choix qui est fait c'est d'aller vers
la société du Pôle emploi il faut pas
asphyxier vos entreprises donc on fait
pas porter les forces entreprises pour
être clair
soignante depuis plus de 23 ans et les
épaules le dos ramassent énormément les
personnes à partir de 55 ans ils sont en
maladie professionnelle ne faut-il pas
un moment donné dans notre société posez
aussi autour de la table un sujet qui
est le sujet de comment on gère les fins
de carrière mais pourquoi ne pas le
faire avant cette réforme en fait on a
le sentiment que les choses sont faites
à l'envers donc moi je suis contre cette
réforme pour moi c'est inacceptable même
c'est ça provoque de la colère chez moi
quelle est la contrainte que l'on met au
niveau des pour qu'effectivement ils
assurent l'embauche des seniors ça me
dérange pas comme disent je suis opposé
j'aimerais aussi entendre des
propositions alternatives et vraiment
qu'elle soit portée il y a peut-être des
idées à aller chercher dans des pays
voisins ou scandinave sur comment on
améliore donc la prise en compte des
carrières des fins de carrière des de ce
qu'on appelle les seniors je suis
sincèrement ravi de d'avoir eu ce temps
d'échange avec vous merci et bonne
soirée le député
a de pas sûr
j'avais pas besoin je la confirme bien
ce que j'en pensais moi je vais
travailler peut-être deux trois ans de
plus voilà alors que j'ai déjà mes 43
années donc c'est injuste c'est très
injuste
aujourd'hui 72% des Français sont
opposés à la réforme jusqu'à 93% chez
les seules actifs
autant dire que les députés qui la
combattent ont l'attache plus facile à
Paris Daniel Simonet s'est voulu
inventif pour peser dans le débat
installez-vous approchez-vous fermez toi
là comme ça
ça va depuis la manif elle faisait froid
ah là là là
c'est bien de venir ici des
sympathisants et les filles mais pas
seulement il y a aussi des voisins des
frères et soeurs de militants qui ont
voulu en savoir plus
bienvenue pour ce petit
café populaire retraite dans cette
grande bataille contre la réforme des
retraites et bien en plus des meetings
des manifestations des soutiens à la
grève on a décidé aussi d'organiser des
petits réunions de quartier donc là vous
avez le projet de loi première atelier
en revenir au texte de la réforme et au
fameux articles 7 de la loi de finances
rectificative de la sécurité sociale qui
n'a aucune ambiguïté
ça c'est terrible et c'est trois mois de
plus en agilité par donc ça veut dire
prolonger encore
le travail de ceux qui sont fatigués
mais au-delà du fond ce qui les révolte
c'est la méthode utilisée pour faire
passer cette réforme qui est scandaleux
c'est évidemment l'artiste 47 1 puisque
là c'est une volonté le faire qui ait
pas le moins de débat possible parce
qu'ils ont tellement peur du mouvement
dans la rue et ils ont tellement peur il
faut pris de leur propre majorité ils
tiennent rien c'est une volonté
uniquement du président qui veulent
faire des trucs très rapides alors la
députée va essayer de transformer son
auditoire en ambassadeur de la lutte
autrement dit leur donner des armes
rhétoriques pour contrer les arguments
des proresformes alors l'argument qui
nous disent tout le temps c'est ah bah
il faut bien faire cette réforme parce
que on commence à avoir plus de
retraités que d'actifs en raison de
l'évolution démographique est-ce que il
y a quelqu'un qui a envie de donner des
contre-arguments à cet argument que le
gouvernement donne souvent la
productivité elle a été multipliée une
fois par
8 depuis les années 60 donc à un moment
donné on se demande pourquoi on est on
travaille pour qui j'allais dire est-ce
que c'est pour nous pour permettre
justement d'avoir des salaires décents
des retraites descentes ou est-ce que
c'est pour les actionnaires du CAC 40 il
faut sauver notre système de retraite
par répartition alors qui veut contrer
cet argument là
d'après le corps il y a pas de il y a
pas de problème en fait le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites et alors il
dit quoi le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites
et 12 milliards actuellement il est
excédentaire notre système de retraite
voilà au final on se promet de créer une
caisse de greffe pour soutenir les
actions et de se retrouver en
manifestation
s'opposer sans manifester c'est le
numéro d'équilibriste que réalise dans
leur le député RN alors pour être bien
compris de ces électeurs Kevin mon vieux
a clarifié les choses sur sa permanence
et il va leur expliquer en porte-à-porte
traque en main
et chiffres à l'appui
mettre les gens au boulot jusqu'à 64 ans
quand on a 17 % de chômeurs chez les
moins de 30 ans et que à partir de 55
ans il y a qu'une personne sur deux qui
bosse
je pense que tout est dit donc on ferait
mieux déjà de trouver du boulot ce qu'on
a besoin avant de demander à ceux qu'on
soit 62 ans d'aller travailler deux ans
de plus sachant qu'ils ne peuvent pas
tous et puis des acquis sociaux que les
anciens ils ont gagné et je trouve ça
l'avantage de perdre tout ça et puis
alors que c'est pas nécessaire en plus
[Musique]
riche enrichit il y a quelque chose qui
merci pour l'accueil au revoir pour se
démarquer dans l'opposition il a une
botte secrète la motion référendaire
déposée par les députés RN donc en gros
nous rassemblement national on a déposé
un texte à l'Assemblée pour demander à
ce que la réforme des retraites soit
faite par référendum et lundi après-midi
les députés vont tous voter pour ou
contre ce truc là donc en gros nous au
rassemblement national on va voter pour
un référendum
maintenant faut espérer que les autres
le fassent
s'exprimer donc pour moi je suis
vraiment pour le référendum bonjour
pourtant favorable au référendum la
nupesse a annoncé ne pas vouloir voter
une motion
issue du rassemblement national
mais Kévin ma vieux pense que rien n'est
perdu pour autant
au début il y a deux ou trois semaines
j'étais pessimiste à l'Assemblée
nationale quand j'écoutais les autres
députés etc j'étais pessimiste et je me
disais qu'elle allait passer quoi qu'il
arrive aujourd'hui il y a des députés
les républicains qui disaient qu'ils
étaient pour et qui commencent à dire
finalement on va voter contre parce
qu'il sent que les gens ça les saoule
soutenir ou pas la réforme c'est en
effet le dilemme de bon nombre de
députés LR
et c'est le cas de celui de la première
circonscription des Vosges
quand il va prendre le pouls de la
situation sur le marché d'Épinal
Stéphane Viry sent bien que certains de
ses électeurs ils sont très favorables
j'ai travaillé jusqu'à 69 ans
j'en suis pas mort je suis encore là à
75 ans 76
la valeur travail m'a donné du punch
mais il est tout de même surpris par
certains cas individuels
c'est aller j'avais quel âge 15 ans 16
ans et quand je suis venue sur Épinal
avec mon mari j'ai perdu quatre ans
et là 63 ans tu peux encore pas partir
donc c'est 67 ans pour toi ah ouais 4
ans encore on a dit on arrivera
peut-être avec le déambulateur au
travail
votre a votre appât
devons ces partisans le député a l'air
dit encore hésiter en tout cas ne pas
donner un blanc sain au gouvernement moi
je conseille effectivement que ce projet
de loi il est largement perfectible mais
qu'on peut pas reprocher au gouvernement
de mettre la question sur la table qui
ne pense pas qu'il y a des inégalités
que celles et ceux qui ont subi une
profession dure puisse partir plus tôt
contiennent davantage compte peut-être
de la durée de cotisation plutôt que de
l'âge légal
moi je considère que c'est sur lequel il
faut avancer oubliez le totem des 64 ans
tout en allongeant la durée de
cotisation serait selon Stéphane Viry
sans doute plus juste
la retraite c'est plutôt la durée de
cotisation il faut augmenter
totalement d'accord tu vois la durée de
cotisation plutôt que las vegal tu vois
une fois que tu as donné ta code barre
de 43 on te fout la paix tu as le droit
de partir
autrement si tu as 44-45 etc donc la
durée de cotisation pour moi c'est c'est
ça la mère des réformes et pour moi en
fait las Vega en plus là je les garde ça
a l'air tout le monde
et c'est pas le système le plus juste
on est loin de la ligne du parti
pourtant ces voies des républicains
s'annoncent capitale dans le processus
la majorité présidentielle va en avoir
besoin pour faire voter sa réforme sans
passer renforce